every element is defined by the number
of protons in its atoms which is called
its atomic number
so for example every atom of potassium
has 19 protons and every atom of cobalt
has 27 protons but what about neutrons
well an element doesn't always have the
same number of neutrons in its atoms
atoms of the same element with different
numbers of neutrons are called isotopes
because isotopes of an element have
different numbers of neutrons those
Isotopes also have different masses
remember most of the mass of an atom
comes from the protons and neutrons in
its nucleus in fact the sum of the
number of protons and neutrons in an
atom is called its mass number
we can write this in the form of an
equation as follows mass number equals
the number of protons plus the number of
neutrons
next let's dive into isotope notation or
how we represent Isotopes in writing
when describing different isotopes
you'll often see this notation where X
is the chemical symbol which is an
abbreviation of the element's name a is
the mass number the number of protons
plus neutrons and Z is the atomic number
the number of protons
let's practice writing out the notation
for different isotopes we'll start with
carbon which has an atomic number of six
in nature carbon is mainly composed of
two different isotopes one of these
Isotopes has six neutrons and the other
isotope has seven neutrons let's start
with the isotope that has six protons
and six neutrons with that information
we know that the mass number must be 12
which is the sum of the protons and
neutrons
so the notation for this isotope of
carbon would look like this
we have the chemical symbol C with the
mass number 12 written at its top left
and the atomic number six written at its
bottom left
but for the isotope with six protons and
seven neutrons the mass number would be
six plus seven or thirteen so the
notation for the carbon isotope would be
as follows
here we have the chemical symbol C with
the mass number 13 written at its top
left and the atomic number six written
at its bottom left
notice that the chemical symbol and
atomic number share the same information
the identity of the element and are the
same for both isotopes
but the mass number is different for
each isotope depending on the number of
neutrons
another notation that is used for
Isotopes is the chemical symbol or the
element's name symbolized by X followed
by a hyphen and the mass number
symbolized by a so X hyphen a
let's return to our carbon Isotopes
example for the carbon isotope that has
six protons and six neutrons we write
that as c hyphen 12 or carbon 12. for
the carbon isotope with six protons and
seven neutrons we write that as c hyphen
13 or carbon 13.
let's wrap up this video with a quick
recap we know that elements are defined
by the number of protons in their atoms
but atoms of the same element can have
different numbers of neutrons these are
called isotopes
because Isotopes have different numbers
of neutrons they also have different
Mass numbers which are the sum of the
protons and neutrons in each Isotopes
atom
and Adam's mass number can be described
by the equation mass number equals the
number of protons plus the number of
neutrons
and lastly we can describe Isotopes
using a couple of different notations
which are shown below